[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream we are having a
tsunami of fun here
at the dark horse podcast
what
it's unfortunate well i tried it it
didn't work but you know these are
terrifying yes they are they are they're
mostly made of water though
all right
discord question this week wait no
corrections from just a few minutes ago
okay the
website for the for the march is defeat
the mandates dc.com
so
anyway i wish i could go back in time
and fix that a lot of people are going
to be searching and not finding but
put that into the show notes defeat the
mandates
dc.com yeah
okay
uh what else that was only one
correction no
uh well surely you can come up with
another correction
i'm not gonna say it i'm gonna resist
it's too hackneyed oh
okay
yes i can and don't call me surely
that's what i'm not gonna say um
yes no i think that's it i mean i also
you know i i think i covered really well
so people will not notice that i missed
the three
reasons that we must defeat the mandates
that uh
the remedies are not sufficiently
safe and effective the public health
authorities are not immune to corruption
and the disease itself does not justify
them but not this disease not this
treatment not this government yeah
it's that yeah um and also on top of it
all
it's un-american this is a last resort
using mandates and we are not at the
place where one resorts to the last
resort
oh but some people are scared to go to
school so it must be a national
emergency look man i've always been
scared to go to school and i maintain i
was right about the place all along and
now the rest of you are catching up
no no
um this week's discord question i am not
prepared to address but i will ask it
and see if you are prepared to address
it wow
could we attempt to debunk the uasc
beijing mouse paper by testing omicron
s1 affinity with ace2 in a wild type mus
musculus from south africa
they used a blast must-musculus model in
their study i believe that you can't
prove zoonosis this way
i don't know the paper
i know the paper i don't know it well
but i agree with this thinking exactly
that this is a hypothesis in need of a
separate test and that sounds broad
brush
you by which you mean you think that the
hypothesis that they claim to have
tested in this paper was not actually
tested i would want to go back and make
sure that they claim to test the
hypothesis but yes i believe
so it could be that it's just a
hypothesis that they advance on the
basis of their interesting observation
but
let's just say
a a lot rides on this because as we've
talked about before
either so there's there's just this
incredible weirdness about omicron at
the genomic level well let me just
interject you know like with the
original kovid lab leak or not actually
really does matter it does really does
have real world ramifications this is
not just some ivory tower well yes why
don't you figure that out after we get
the world back together like no this
actually has ramifications it has
serious implications i mean and you know
they go in both directions but
nonetheless we do need to know which
means we need
uh something other than a single line of
evidence that just allows us to dismiss
this
um
well this dismiss lab origin in favor
right so what we've got is an anomaly
where something that is derived from a
basal lineage emerges with a tremendous
number of alterations and so the
proposal in this paper is that what
happened is it moved into mice was
selected for
uh
for transmission in mice which is a very
strong selective force because coming
from humans and going to mice would
create a lot of differences
and then re-emerge to people
and so that's like voila where was it
was it in a lab somewhere and then got
modified
so anyway very interesting if it's true
but yes you do want to test it some
other way certainly a plausible story
yeah yeah well i i don't know if anybody
knows if it's a plausible story it's a
plausible story theoretically for some
some some thing could have followed that
path yes it is not yeah something could
have followed that path and
possibly it would account for the
anomalies here so anyway yes i
definitely want to see clever people
figure out how to test this against
things like uh
but i don't remember i mean i once knew
but i don't remember what blast i i just
don't remember the various ways that
these mice get tinkered so i don't
remember blast versus wild type
so i would i would just point out that
one of the things several people
including i have said is
if mice that's also interesting right
we've seen this virus
move to ferrets
uh and links and ferrets are a very
likely laboratory animal um humanized
mice are also very likely to have been
used in the production of the original
thesaurus cov2 still one of the phrases
that you use occasionally that
immediately sends
very creepy shivers down my spine
humanized mice yeah
that's the one well i mean i think a lot
of people who have them anthropomorphize
mice but this is a this is more
molecular
and malevolent yes
all right shall we move on
um
yes we shall oh hold on i have not
oh
i just made all the questions
disappeared
no i just made all the questions
disappear come on
oh boy oh i can't see any of them now
well it does leave one with a lot of
questions there were a lot of good
questions too oh my god the entire thing
is down
uh there we go it's back oh nope i'm not
signed in though hold on so you just
you're from italy i got to sign back in
it dropped me out
i'm going to riff oh actually it just
pretended to drop me out you're back i
think so all right except i can't i
can't see anything i think i'm doing it
by score but i can't
are the lights on
nothing is showing but um
my friend
don't
on the computer
hello friend okay um
lots of lots of cool varied questions
here and now that it upset all of my
organization i'm just going to read from
the top
a trait is considered good
relative to its niche but humans are
niche switchers
does this imply that there is or could
be a trait that is advantageous across
all or most niches and thus is
objectively superior
yeah i mean and yeah that's i like i
like the the frame egg here yeah there
are lots of things um that will work in
any niche i mean for one thing
the human species
has recently
not recently like in human history but
recently in our the evolution of our
lineage had a major increase in our
maximum longevity
right that's good
right more time gives you more
opportunity
to
reproduce and produce more people to
refine
things that you understood anyway
so basically any niche and it's a
positive thing and lots of things will
be that way if you came up with an
adaptation that
increased the efficiency with which you
transported oxygen
around your body
that would be good in any niche so yeah
there are lots of things that would be
general
um
and niche switching itself is something
that is useful anywhere because you know
niche switching when we say it we mean
something big like you know i was
fishing on the coast and now i'm
um
hunting large mammals inland but it can
also mean little tiny things right yeah
very small alterations where you figure
out how to do something that your
ancestors couldn't do and it contributes
to your lineage's well-being so that
ability to bootstrap new software
is useful anywhere and everywhere even
if your niche is one that you'll have
for a good long time
so i think the short answer is yep yep
no i like it i like the framing
uh recurring upsetting dreams of a
specific theme like regrets or school
testing
your brain's way of inspiring you to fix
your life
a cue from your environment or things
eaten or a cruel joke
uh i
have a relationship with these things
uh not recently but when i was much
younger i had some recurring
uh not so positively themed dreams
especially around
scholastic disasters see earlier point
about school being a very terrible place
scholasters
all right scholasters if you will and
they will portmanteau
i've never been
um still not high right
no still not
unfortunately um in any case
dreams oh yeah yeah you're you're um
right you showed up to a final of a
class you've never been to right right
that's the dreams you had right it was a
dream calculus i think yeah but here's
and then you and i took calculus
together yeah and you did well i did
really well but um
but here's the point i had nightmares
about
the class that i didn't know was taking
place that was on the schedule that i
didn't drop
all too plausible that this would happen
to me and that you know you discover
that the class is happening on the day
of the final you're trying to find where
the class is you walk in the final
contains things you've never seen before
right it's all that but here's the thing
what's the opposite of alienating
uh
uh enticing yeah you're simultaneously
enticing and half the audience and
alienating the other half
right exactly and as long as you
alienate the right people it's a good
thing
um
your point being yourself the point
where i interrupted you that i had a
certain amount of anxiety around
calculus not because i wasn't going to
be able to do calculus well but it is
exactly the kind of course that
could challenge my organization's
structures in a way that i would not
have succeeded in it by perhaps not
attending and
for instance for example or spending the
book ever
doing any of the problems in any case
here's the salient point now that we've
outed me thoroughly 16 different ways
and they were not awesome but in any
case now that we've done that the point
is this i never had another dream about
calculus
after i had after you aced calculus
right
never
it went away and so it didn't get
replaced with a dream about
chemistry
no no i mean i had some of those that
were general but the point is at the
point that my
internal dream making sense knew that i
was
not going to
fall victim to this particular error
yeah it stopped bothering me with it and
that tells me the answer to your
question which is
it's an adaptive trait and frankly
the thing that i can't establish is true
but may well be
is that it scared me enough that the bad
thing didn't happen and that's the point
right that it's a it's a way i think it
is a way you said to test that
hypothesis you would have had to have
taken calculus without me taking it with
you
not going to happen i get it that i um
i was not using fear but my presence
as someone who was enthusiastic about
calculus and was going to show up and do
the problems and learn the stuff and i
was excited for us to be learning it
together
means that you hardly ran the experiment
right i didn't but it also establishes
that i am a very clever person who uh
found you irresistible and there were
just so many great things that flowed
from that including i didn't have to
worry about
failing out of graduate school
uh as a result of not doing this no that
was santa cruz it was underground yeah
you're right yeah all right in any case
it's a santa cruz which is currently
under water it seems
not totally good my god yeah that's a
long way water really isn't compressible
it's not compressed
and many things flow from that literally
yeah so uh the volcano in tonga
yesterday has indeed produced tsunami
conditions in santa cruz california
today now and san diego pacifica was it
was the other image you saw yeah and
actually
so we remember back uh was it i always
forget was the boxing day tsunami 2004
six
five
somewhere in that neighborhood in any
case we remember
the
maybe it wasn't that tsunami six there
was a tsunami back in that area i i
think it was the boxing day tsunami
that produced
a very small but visible tsunami in
santa cruz no no that was a different i
think i think that was a different
one i thought maybe maybe not but i
remember seeing yes video
in santa cruz from some event that had
taken
um place
an ocean away yeah
uh in which there were there was damage
to the boats in the harbor and all of
this it's like that that's extraordinary
and it did i mean santa cruz is the top
of this big bay yeah then it's straight
i mean it it looks like it would be
slightly protected but it appears to be
in a place that is just exactly smacked
by
um at least tsunami conditions that are
coming from the south ish
from the west and from the south ish yep
but this one uh i've seen some
impressive video already from from the
u.s west coast yeah um really really
something yeah but yeah as you say water
is not compressible and so you basically
the energy from these things
ricochets around uh
yeah it's incredible and tonga can't be
having a good time with it
i saw something i don't know what their
highest point is but it can't be that
high
no
um i i saw some
footage of people appearing to play with
the damn thing
which is pretty scary like surf it is
you know like
uh run in front of it
uh you know 3d cameras on poles
um you know and
so i recall from i i spent how about put
your 3d camera on a pole and then take a
boat out to the open ocean
and survive it there
yeah but
i wouldn't see as much but
anyway i do recall there was a rule that
was discussed during the boxing day
synonymy or right after it
about
if you were touched by the water you had
something like
an 80 or 90 chance of dying oh really
yeah 2004 turns out it wasn't four yeah
um
wow so anyway yeah
that makes that that makes sense okay um
i don't know if we totally answered that
um your brain's way of inspiring me to
fix your life a cue from your
environment or things eating or a cruel
joke you know
sometimes that intermediate thing as
well a cue from your environment or
things
well
you can have lots of uh stray
you know
do your eyes transmit signals to your
brain in order for you to know what the
world around you looks like
yes but if you hit yourself in the eye
you may see a flash of light because you
drive the pressure up on this neuron so
it's not like any signal that flows down
that pipe means the thing in question
and there's psychoactive stuff in a lot
of food and you know which which
if you know whatever you eat whatever
your last meal is before you go to bed
may well have effects on your dream
state right so you should make sure it's
psycho passive food
in order that i would say the opposite
oh all right well i mean it depends you
know mix it with your alcohol you know
reveal to the people how much power you
have to give them joy if you sleep on
the edge
that's what we do around here we sleep
on the edge
all right i've been oh i've been in
lockdown in austria for two months i
have 1500 plus antibodies but i'm losing
hope
which vaccine is the least scary mrna or
alternative
um
depends on what the alternative is but
um
here in the u.s we have access to three
um
and i've advised
friends and family who
need to get them um
the alternative jnj
i think it's actually a tough call yeah
um it's a tough call for various reasons
because you've got factors like how many
injections so you know a shot that's
worse but you get less of it um
is
you know it's hard to compare these
things and i think well that's i mean
the distinction between madarina and
pfizer one of them is just the the
amount and that probably
it seems that one of the reasons that uh
pfizer is causing uh fewer adverse
events than moderna is simply the
abundance that modernity has more of the
stuff in it
and
so between those two
pfizer seems a better choice
but
it's tough to say
hi from queensland australia have you
seen topher fields battleground
melbourne i'd love you guys to review it
yeah i don't know do you know what zach
um i'm sorry
have you heard of topher fields
battleground
melbourne
okay
i am
it's now up it's one of my tabs
isn't promising a lot but it's now an
open tab in my browser
okay
let's see
are the
the disproportional deaths in the
unvaccinated
dying in hospitals people so frail that
they can't take the vaccine
and survive
if so
wouldn't that be a vaccine scam
um
these things have to be
addressed very carefully statistically
because there are so many ways that you
can get an effect that seems to imply
one thing and implies something else and
i would just give you an example having
nothing to do with vaccines
um
but it's a famous example in which
bombers
during world war ii
were
suffering terrible losses and the
decision was made
to armor them so that they would endure
the flack and bullets that they were
taking better than than they had been
and
what was
discovered
effectively was
that it was best to armor them if you
looked at the bombers that came back
there were places where they were shot
up and were riddled with holes and there
were places that they weren't touched
and it seems like well you should armor
them where they're riddled with holes
and it's exactly the opposite of right
the right answer is the places where
they didn't have any holes or the places
where anything that got a hole didn't
come back yeah and so the armor goes
where they don't
come back with holes
anyway there are lots of things like
this where you it's such an amazing
story every time you tell it i'm
surprised and new it's just it's
remarkable just really you know once
you've seen it and you realize that you
can get fooled into seeing exactly the
opposite of what's in front of you
um you don't unsee it yeah that's world
war ii you said yeah yeah
amazing
um
okay so next up we have a complaint
about the
odyssey moderator claiming that he calls
people idiots um which
i don't i doubt that really happens i'm
not going to read the whole question
yep
um
why does human head hair grow
continuously
how might something like that evolve
gyms don't have it do we know when it
came into humans
um this is a good question yeah
you should just know that there is a
formal distinction drawn between fur and
hair and fur is self-limiting
hair hair that grows at itself actually
we have a prop right here
check this out all right
this is one of these cats that i swear
with another three or four thousand
years of refinement would be an
excellent house pet
he has what's called a goodie fur so in
a goodie fur is a fur that has different
bands each individual
fur
has
stripes on it effectively which tells
you that there's a process
in which the hair follicle that produces
it
is basically aware of how of whether
it's just starting a hair right in order
for all those bands to line up to give
him the pretty stripes he's got a strand
rather than a hair it's not hair exactly
your point but man a goody hair would be
gorgeous man that would be that would
give us stripes we'd have the stripes
that really people would be so much more
beautiful with stripes totally yeah yeah
yeah but we don't have a goody hair but
he has a duty fur we don't but what we
have is ever growing hair and the
question really is what was this you
know this formal distinction that you
poured out between fur and hair always
struck me as just yet another place that
humans decided that because we do it
differently it deserves a different name
and aren't we all super awesome
i mean it is different yeah
i see it as a perfectly useful but then
is you know is the stuff on our arms fur
yep
but no one calls it that
uh i do just not when other people are
around arm fur
no one calls it that and it should be
because that doesn't grow continuously
right it grows to a length and then it
stops
huh
yeah i i think it is fur
uh i think it is but no one calls it
that if it's humans it's hair because
we're not like them beasts
well but the thing is all right
i mean i take your point we're not
perfectly consistent about it but um
we do have something weird going on on
the tops of our heads oh for sure and it
has a lot of evolutionary mysteries in
it like why would evolution
take a fur program and change it to a
hair program it could be
because humans have used modification of
hair to signal various things
group affiliation
sex differences whatever and so the
point was having a having a canvas that
was amenable to being modified might
have been useful to relatively recent
ancestors
um
so i've never seen the attempt made but
i do wonder about the character state
evolution the the ordered-ness of
becoming hairless and obviously we're
not hairless but becoming relatively
more hairless than any of our close
ancestors and so the two big changes
with regard to our pellege as it were is
becoming relatively hairless and
which is of course the wrong word again
becoming relatively furless
and then
keeping
pellege
which i think is the correct term that
includes both on top of our heads that
grows continuously right and then
weirdly fails in men some percentage of
the time
in a systematic way okay but that's
obviously late in terms of character
state evolution that's downstream and
obviously and somewhat less important
i'm i'm interested in the
to get from chimp
chimp and bonobo like chimp bonobo
human-like ancestor um that presumably
had more of the fur distribution of a
like thing into us
two big things happened and are they a
related to one another and b if so in
what order did they happen
um you know did we were we fully furred
but the stuff up here started to grow
out longer and then we started to lose
the fur here and here and for women all
over here and then we kept it like under
our arms but it's definitely only at one
length and then our genitals and then
you know light dusting over most of our
body except definitely not our hands and
our feet it's a strange distribution
yeah it's a strange distribution it is
indeed a strange distribution um and
interesting alterations with respect to
the one on the head
i don't know i will say we have a
misleading just as we misunderstand
music because
we live in an era in which music can be
exactly repeated and so we don't
understand that songs are supposed to be
living entities that change every time
you sing every time you sing or play one
yeah
we don't understand hair because
frankly and you know
yes please write in and correct me but i
think
that all of us would have dreadlock-like
things
if we lived in pre-modern times and
dreadlock-like things might function
some somehow as an intermediate in other
words they may be self-limiting
rather than through a growth length
limit
there's a limit to how long a dreadlock
can get before it's fragile and
i don't know if this is true yeah i
don't know i you know my um my freshman
year roommate who was a white woman had
dreadlocks but she had to kind of work
to to get them
well no doubt and to maintain them but i
mean what what else do you think would
happen if you lived in pre-modern
circumstances where there was no shampoo
so at most your hair was getting wet
don't you think dreadlocks would be more
or less automatic i'm not i'm not
convinced of that no i'm not convinced
that um
the
smoother finer hair
like at the microscopic level the
smoother finer hair of like northern
european populations um is i think it is
less likely to dread
than the coarser thicker hair of african
populations but i don't know for sure
yeah
i don't know i i think it would be and
same i would say the smoother finer hair
i think it's smoother finer for sure for
sure smoother i think it's finer which
say smaller diameter of east asian
populations also less likely to dread
yeah i mean you would have to look at um
prehistoric movies or something to get a
sense of
how people look at log books from the
network yeah right
cave paintings maybe but then you know
it's hard to know
i'm trying to think
his hair i can't i can't pull up any
cave paintings of people that have hair
in them
they leave the hair out
no i wouldn't think it's there but i
think it's just not rendered in a i mean
maybe maybe there are instances yeah
uh would you ever consider running
courses or trips as you did with your
old students
our students were not old some of them
were
yeah all right that's fair
um
yeah we have and would and um i will
tell you right now the thing that is
most important if we were to try to do
that
is some mechanism to free heather from
the part of the job that she's so good
at but it is so terrible and does not uh
does not make use of her
extraordinary talents
in other words we would need
we would need logistical support we need
a logistics manager yeah to run the
thing um which
yeah i was
i was excellent at it
um and it helped me create trips that no
one else had created at all before and
thus make them actually affordable to
people who really didn't have very much
money at all
um you know at a cost that was in some
cases a tenth of what
anything of that length and you know
there was nothing comparable either i
did i did not just park students in you
know in dorms in other countries and
walk away like most so-called professors
doing study abroad do
um but yeah as in so much right now like
we could really use um
logistics manager yeah yep now we would
also you know one of the things that we
did uh especially for our last trip i
should say heather round trips without
me but when we did our last trip yeah
with the last one we did together and it
was the longest and it was it was
amazing
but we had a lot of room and
this was kind of necessary we had a lot
of room to put students through their
paces before we committed to taking them
abroad
and the problem is if we were to do
trips like that now we wouldn't be able
to
well but
i guess i would just say we would have
to use a substitute mechanism
like if you turn out to be
a lot of trouble we feed you to the
cayman or something
or i remember on one trip
we had
um i had uh
your former student and my then current
student rob who was uh um
he was trouble
he was definitely not trouble he was
awesome and he was my right-hand man and
he you know he he saves lives on renier
i don't actually know that he does that
anymore but um one of the ways one of
the things that he was doing
uh was he had been both a back country
guide and uh and a river rafting guide
but he was actually doing uh rescue
search and rescue uh on the volcanoes
around here and um he showed me some of
his stuff that he had used to help lead
trips to train other people to do this
and i was talking about you know what to
do if someone should fall into a
crevasse and how you really needed to
avoid falling into a crevasse and i was
like all we have to do is change every
instance of the word crevasse into
anaconda and we can just use this for
this trip and like just make sure people
don't fall into an anaconda and we're
fine how do we train people to fall into
an anaconda we're good right the first
rule is nobody comes home in a box the
second rule is nobody falls into an
anaconda because we don't want to have
to go in after you no we're not going to
frankly you know if we leave an ankle
showing yank a few times but but at some
level you're kind of on your own at that
point i think so yeah rob interestingly
um as you know uh
is mennonite yes i mean during the day
too but especially at night
he actually is
yep yep
also pulled off the most incredible
genetic gymnastic stunt that either of
us have ever imagined or seen and we get
to see it with our very own eyes oh my
gosh shall we all right let's describe i
feel like rob wrote me last month that i
didn't respond so rob i think i think
he's in ecuador again with with the
volcanoes like he's climbing
well so here's the story so um we had a
shop building when we were in olympia
and we had a roof put on that wasn't any
good and we ended up having to put
another roof on and i said to myself i
am not re-roofing this building unless
it's for good i'm putting a metal roof
on this building
and uh anyway i was trying to find
somebody to put a metal roof on and rob
had roofing experience and he was like
you know he'd also worked as a roofer
yeah i think i know i i think i could it
was a simple enough building i think i
can do your your metal roof and so i
agreed to work with him and he was the
the boss on the job and yeah we roofed
that was good paid him well but uh spent
a little less than we would have if you
hadn't been the second worker and yep
anyway so we hired some friends and you
know pulled off the old roof and cleared
out the nails and replaced the sheets
that needed replacing all the stuff one
does and finally at the end of the job
what hold on this is uh how how high is
the lower edge of the roof because 12
feet at its lowest at its lowest and it
peaked at 20 yeah yeah because it was
like a one and a half it had a it had a
loft area inside for storage yeah so
anyway we put the roof on this building
and it was the last day and the rain was
descending and so we had like an
electrical storm we had a major election
we started rushing to get the thing
done
and anyway the rain was descending and
it was beginning to fall and we what
does the ground look like though
well the ground is
we'll get there okay he so we're trying
to get all of the equipment that we've
been using off the roof so we had sort
of camped out up there for however many
days it took us to put the roof on and
so we had equipment of all kinds you
know
up there and we were taking it off we
were going to the edge of the roof and
uh you know climbing down with a bucket
full of
tools and all of this
and at the very last stage rob was
looking at what he had accomplished here
having removed this building and feeling
justly proud of it and he um
was sweeping
the roof so that it would be pristine at
the beginning of its life as a fully
fledged roof
and um
i was descending with a bucket of tools
down the
extension ladder
and i got i was coming down i'd gotten
below the level of the roof and i heard
thump
and i thought
what
and then i look
he having heard some sort of scraping
noise and i see rob
you see the broom first oh first i see
the broom right the broom thank you zach
the broom goes sliding off the roof and
plunges to the ground into
a the basically the parking lot of the
building which has a trailer in it it's
got rakes and shovels lumber with nails
in it right it's a mess and rob then
flies off the edge of this roof
lands
does the deepest squat possible
leaps
up to his feet with the most beautiful
smile on his face and i was watching
this thing from right below roof level i
saw every second of it
and i said
rob did you do that intentionally he
said no
so what he had done was he had put a
sheet of water but he had used the broom
and he had created a layer of water
and he slipped in it and then so he's
used to sliding down glaciers and all
this stuff and he had told me at the
beginning when we put this roof on he
said listen to me
if you fall up here what you're going to
do is you're going to flip over and
you're going to grab the seams of the
roof
in order to stop you
so i had held this as sort of the way
i'm not gonna fall off the roof
and uh i was like well why didn't you
stop yourself i said i tried it didn't
work and so he had actually but he also
knew that at the base of the roof right
by the gutter line or all of these
raised nail heads
yeah they're uh screws and bolts yeah
yeah and so anyway he had as he realized
he was sliding and his gripping the
seams of the roof thing wasn't gonna
work he leapt over the line of screws
landed on his feet anyway it was it was
quite beautiful yeah yeah
did i mention that he's mennonite all
right
this loom's large for you yeah
and
with his help no one fell into an
anaconda on either of our watch right
yeah
i don't remember why we were talking
about that um it had to do with i don't
know yeah either
um
hey y'all i just wanted to say thank you
all for all
thank you for all y'all do
dark course is the only podcast i have
set on reminder my hope is everyone will
remember we always have choices choose
freedom and happiness love and light
thank you
thank you sally excellent yes thank you
this is from my friend connor in light
of the public hearings on classifying
the ivory build woodpecker
i'm going to start over yeah yeah
in light of the public hearings i'm
classifying the ivory-billed woodpecker
as extinct
are you ivory-billed truthers or do you
think they are truly extinct
oh i'm a distinction denialist
distinction to not oh distinction
denialist is that what you said that's
not what i meant but i'm going to go
with it yes
i do not mean i do not believe they're a
distinct species
well isn't that what you said that's
what i did not mean to say okay i'm
going to say
that i was going to be an extinction
nihilist so you were does that make you
a truther i don't know i was hoping to
evacuate no that's the other no that's
the other thing your extension you're a
distinct are you actually distinction
denialist no um
here's the thing i think
i don't think no i think they're
actually still it's plausible they're
still very common
but they're being
misdescribed as a closely related
i don't know um
it's very hard to prove there are no
more of them
true but you know you're not actually a
distinction denialist yeah but you are
an extension an extinction denialist
you're an extinction skeptic you're
extinction hesitant i am an extinction
resister
on their behalf i'm not giving up on
this bird
you see what i'm saying yeah if you care
you wouldn't either yeah exactly yeah
yeah
all right i'm not sure if we answered
this question no i love this question
yeah that's a good one i don't know i
hope they're still out there yeah me too
i'd love for them to be out there i'd
love to see and you know you know we
have we have another giant woodpecker
here uh the um
pileated and they are gorgeous and they
and they and they pair bond
and this i don't think they pair bond
throughout the year do they they come
together
i don't know actually i don't know i
don't know we haven't seen many the last
couple years i've seen a few um but not
as many um we use we used to often have
especially up in olympia but here the
first year we were here we had a pair
that would breed nearby and we'd see a
lot of i caught some i was trying to get
a great picture i got some decent stuff
but nothing great but last summer yeah
okay
okay
um but yeah big woodpecker is
amazing i mean i mean all the
woodpeckers are but the bigger
woodpeckers are really quite remarkable
yeah this is a
very odd creature i think what is
there's a big woodpecker in deputy
actually in the amazon um
and i can't think of which one it is at
the moment but just amazing to see
you know when you're in literally the
most biodiverse spot on earth
and yeah there's 10 species of monkeys
and there's five species of felids and
there's anacondas that you're trying not
to fall into and all of this and then
and you know in two cans and parrots and
a lot of other birds that you've never
heard of that are nick watson that are
totally amazing um and then you also see
a giant woodpecker you're like really
tropics like you had to also get a giant
woodpecker yeah do you have enough
i don't think they think of it that way
no they don't at all
okay
could we describe our public health
institutions as having become coveted
paper clip optimizers with added human
failings
oh man
um
you know i mean look i i i applaud i
applaud the effort at the taxonomy here
the
the problem is
the paperclip maximizer is a
mindless well okay there's one way in
which i will defend this i have argued
that the best
the most benign explanation for the
level of catastrophic failure that we
are seeing in public health land
is that
we have
pharma
which has perfected a corruption game
that it plays every day of every week
right under normal circumstances
and
that nobody thought to install a kill
switch on it for an emergency and that
it's just doing that at global scale
with an emergent
uh man-made pandemic
um because it can't help itself it can't
stop right yeah i don't believe for a
second that that's what's going on but i
believe it's part of the explanation and
so that part the idea of a machine you
built for a purpose that just
runs away and it's you know it's the
sorcerer's apprentice with the
um
rooms right
that's a part of it but then there's
another part of this
which involves
very intelligent people
thwarting
certain kinds of action that would be
highly useful and advancing other kinds
of action that is at best pointless and
in many cases harmful and it's very hard
to see that as a paperclip maximizer
because these are actually humans who
could wake the [ __ ] up and stop doing
that yeah
yep good
um your bowerbird discussion with jordan
peterson any evolutionary stories to
share about male birds of paradise and
their unique dance
well
we've never seen them in the wild
unfortunately or have we seen power
birds actually we've never been to that
part of the world yeah it's going to be
a little wild well let's say this
there's actually i would say there are
three clades of birds because of
paradise are also like northern
australia and papua new guinea and i
don't think that's an accident
i think or it's not even what part of
that isn't
and birds of paradise has to do with the
fact that that habitat is actually
favoring this and i'm not going to go
into why i think that is
here and now i think it's a huge
important the answer to that question is
huge and important so you think that
tropics north east of wallace's line
western pacific tropics are particularly
conducive to bowerbird birds of paradise
style theatrics
in a way that we don't see
i mean
elsewhere yes we see right so this but
that but this is my question that i feel
like we do see it elsewhere in which
case what like what what are the similar
ecosystems that's it it so i would argue
that mannequins are very uh bird of
paradise
m-a-n-a-k-i-n-s the birds
and so anyway
here's the teaser for you
i think we've got sexual selection
really wrong i think we've totally
misunderstand what we're misunderstood
we're looking at not all of it
but the part of it that is elaborate
displays uh with female choice
surely there are other
so so for you so these three birds are
all doing elaborate displays they're
lacking yep they're all lacking yep it's
these elaborate like displays um there
are there are other other clades of
birds that lack though yeah oh there's
lots of lacking that goes you can't
think of who they are these are just the
three
super extraordinary and you know there
are super extraordinary ones and you
know
i would point out
that if you uh zoom in a little bit
you've got uh peacock spiders which are
every bit as amazing as any of those
clades they're just you know the size of
your fingernail right right but so we
don't notice them in the same way
but anyway
all of these things need a rethink we've
got some fundamental error in the way we
think about sexual selection and if you
fix it then we understand a lot that we
don't get yet and so anyway i'm not
going to go further than that because
it's too important to to do casually
and i don't know
in terms of just cool natural history
stories about
words of paradise um
they are not
the ones that do the mimicking of
all the sounds that's liar burns which
is also in that same
place
and they're all
are they lacking i don't know maybe they
are yeah but they are um um you know
there's that attenborough clip
uh where his people have caught one
you know the chainsaw the people coming
to chop down the forest they live and
the shutter of the camera the camera
is yeah
um
so i will say
just because
i carry a certain amount of annoyance
about this that when i
finally decided to graduate
from
graduate school
i had a chapter in my dissertation on
this very question and the department
did something bizarre it told me
that i had to remove the latitudinal
diversity chapter or the sexual
selection chapter that it was up to me
which one i wanted to keep but i wasn't
allowed to have both which doesn't make
any sense because
they had a sense of frustration
at the dissertation i was filing but
they couldn't figure out what was wrong
with it and that ought to have been
their indication that actually there
wasn't anything wrong with it and so
then why was i not alone we just don't
like you well they didn't like me which
is fine i really don't like you and you
think about too many things too
effectively and it's really gotten under
our skin i should say it wasn't that
they all didn't like me i polarized the
department yeah um and there were plenty
of people who did like me in fact
absolutely you know there were people
who are now i actually went to bat and
fought bravely on my behalf including
my advisor who's now gone and uh jerry
smith and yeah so anyway it's not like i
was hated
uh but i was polarizing and the
department did try to block it and they
did succeed in blocking me from filing
that chapter um i think because it's
such an insane i mean like those of you
who are academics and we know that in
fact one of the people who's asked the
question
has received a phd in a similar field um
have you ever heard that i've never
heard of another story like that right
and it's not like you know it's not like
like in some fields you can actually do
a dissertation all on a single on a
single piece of research where like one
chapter is the methods and one is the
results that's crazy to me um but for
the most part in our field like you know
my dissertation was all broadly on the
system but they were all distinct
standalone chapters that in some cases i
turned into papers but in most i didn't
but i could have
um but it was all broadly on
a system plus you know a theoretical
review and everything um
but yours was you know each chapter you
know the the thematic
similarities were trade-offs right and
so you wrote a tradeoff chapter and then
you're like okay senescence telomeres
cancer uh latitudinal adversity gradient
uh morality evolution of morality and
also sexual selection and um
they were all so different i mean i did
joke with you like you just need to add
a chapter in astrobiology and you're set
you got it all covered
you prefer the astrobiology from the
other ones right but but uh
i've never ever heard
of of a department doing such a thing
and i guess the setup that i gave was
sort of as cover to departments maybe
which i don't want it to be which is
like yes but no other dissertation has
ever looked like yours did yeah
um but the fact that they gave you a
choice tells you that this was [ __ ]
if they'd been like that chapter doesn't
hold up
no way
um
but that's not what they did they're
like a or b you choose you choose get
rid of one of them but you had yeah and
it was it was it was crazy nonsense um
but i will say
someday i'm gonna get to the sexual
selection thing and it's one of these
things not all questions that have
answers that you have to work a long
time to figure out are this way this
one's very it's a very satisfying answer
right all the little things that annoy a
person when you look
at
um
you know sage grouses or peacocks or
bauer birds and you just think why why
why why why why why it's like oh
if i stand over there this all makes
sense
so for better for worse any phrase that
begins that way now i my brain puts a
hashtag in front of it so now i've got
hashtag not all questions
in my head
fair enough all right
um
did you observe any mantelas feeding
their tadpoles and fertilized eggs as
mantella levigod do did you study that
species thank you
um
yes i was the one who figured that out
yeah isn't that amazing yep yeah heather
heather's dissertation was an absolute
slam dunk and she found out that she did
way more than one needs to do to earn a
phd which is her way um as did you and
they tried to take some of it away well
mine was weirder but yours was all side
projects that i didn't realize were my
dissertation until
at some point they had to be but yep um
but anyway
yes uh heather was the person who worked
all of this out from scratch because
there was like literally nothing known
about your species except where it was
yeah there was there was
the mantellas were actually
it had already been decided because some
of the molecular work had been done that
they weren't sister taxa with the dark
poison frogs but
uh bullinger who had first described
them in the late 1900s had thought that
maybe they were
and um that was still kind of like okay
well maybe maybe behaviorally then
they're going to be too because they've
got the same top so they were known like
phylogenetically they're not dark poison
frogs which is where i'd spent two
seasons doing work on dark poison frogs
in central america
and their toxins are the same which is
fascinating um but we
even knew so there was some chemical
chemistry work that had been done that
had been determined that the skin toxins
in both dark poison frogs and the
mentalines uh were both dietary derived
from the ants and the mites in their
diets
but other than that nothing was known it
had been imagined that maybe they were
going to be some behavioral uh
similarities and the dark poison frogs
were so fascinating from a territorial
and parental care and sexual selection
perspective that maybe some of the
mantelas had some interesting stuff but
madagascar had kicked out the french in
the late 60s and had only recently
within like in the early 90s opened back
up to let vasa to let foreigners white
people come in at all
we had gone there
in 93 as just like a post-college trip
hadn't seen any mantela then i don't
think
um and then at the point that i was like
well okay i can keep working on dark
poison frogs and probably go into south
america and try to discover some things
about one of these species that's less
well known but it's kind of brick in the
wall style understanding and i'll be
able to go deeper into some of the
theoretical stuff probably
or i could take my chances and go to
madagascar where no one knows anything
about these guys you barely there's no
sites described even like you know i i
can i'll do a site scouting trip and we
did that we did a site scouting trip
together
um in
let's say 96
um and i found the site and i didn't
even know what species we looked at
around tiaka we looked at lava gada we
looked at a few others we found a new
species
that we wanted to name
mantella harry rubinai after your
grandfather it turns out
somebody else had found it yeah that's
all i was like i have the i have the
more interesting story but um i'll just
leave it at someone else has claims on
it and it's still not named and that's
super irritating um but and somewhere
it's still not named and somewhere you
have the pictures of this frog still
right that was at andrano bay yeah right
um so anyway i went back and spent um
one very long field season there um in
97 and then went back and spent just a
slightly shorter field season there in
99 with you
both times i also had a field assistant
with me and yeah just everything
everything behaviorally um that is known
about mantella either was from my
research or uh it's downstream of it i
will say though the
number so you've got frogs that very
superficially look like poison dart
frogs in madagascar enough that they
were initially wrongly classified as
close relatives which they are not but
from
okay they share a toxin that they get
from their food
to
a shocking number of other traits
incredible conversions they are in
right down to that little tick tick tick
call right it's like so poison dart frog
that you just have to ask the question
about what force
has shaped these two things into nearly
identical creatures when they're not
closely related yeah and that's that's
effectively that the first chapter of my
dissertation is the incredible power of
adaptation and convergence and look at
the incredible shared convergence of
these two things
that really that you know their history
their shared history is
many
boy i'd have to remind myself
tends to at over 100 million years ago
they have just not been the same frog
for a very very long time obviously
their most recent common answer is a
frog but it's not a poison frog it's not
a diurnal frog it's not a social frog
it's not a parental caregiving frog
it's you know maybe a territorial frog
but but it's it's a case like um
you know like
mannequins and birds of paradise yeah
you know where something very similar
has shaped
systems that look really really a lot
alike now in the case of mantella it's
even closer than mannequins and and um
and birds of paradise and gender batteds
yeah yeah um
but anyway yeah heather sorted the whole
thing out including finding a
major paris parasitic system of her
frogs um including uh figuring out what
the pattern of courtship is including
the trophic uh the unfertilized trophic
eggs including something that i don't
know has been discovered in the poison
dart frogs
um is the the lunchbox hypothesis is
that
yeah i actually that was kyle summers in
denver bad it's in the in the dark i've
seen in the new world yep so heather uh
showed that there was the laying of
er that basically a male could trick a
female into laying an egg that she
thought was going to be a tadpole in a
well that the male already knew had a
tadpole and so it was food for his
offspring and it was a well he wins
either way so you know
most of the audience doesn't care at all
about this but so you've got these
you've got these wells um that are going
to vary in height
based on on weather conditions right
when it rains they get higher when you
have long days of hot of hot dryness
they get lower and you've got a tadpole
that needs to develop it needs to
metamorphose and have legs before the
well dries out entirely and
it subsists
almost entirely on
eggs of self and so mom comes back every
few days um i
i don't i don't actually i'm not sure of
a totally regular periodicity but
something like four to six days mom
comes back and deposits unfertilized egg
into the well for the for the kid to eat
um but the tadpoles are seem to be
selected to be cryptic they hide and if
you don't know for sure there's a
tadpole in there um you really sometimes
can't find them and so the male who's
defending this the successful
territorial male who's defending this
well that has a tadpole already in it
will a hundred percent not cease his
attempts to court other females she'll
come in and if she her the thing she
cares about most is the quality of the
well she actually doesn't care much
about the male
um or the male quality or how persistent
he is he won't admit this he thinks he
thinks that it's everything he's doing
the song the dance he does this
elaborate like ritual rubbing his chin
on her back and he's singing at her he's
doing all these elaborate things she's
like can you just show me the place i
just want to see the place he thinks
he's the best she's ever had yeah and
she's like sure buddy that's fine can
you please just show okay and so she
goes and she looks and really it's
dependent on if there is already a
tadpole in there how good that guy is
yeah at hiding and so that pool that ted
if she sees the tadpole game over she's
not gonna she's not gonna have sex with
this guy yeah if she doesn't see him and
everything else about the water uh it
has to be pretty low ph it has to have
relatively low conductivity it has to
have relatively high dissolved oxygen
these were separate other measures that
i was
keeping track of
it has to be relatively high because it
can get hot and dry and that water level
can can disappear pretty rapidly then
she will lay an egg just above the water
line just above the water line
but if she lays an egg just above the
water line in a well in which there's
already a tadpole and that tadpole
maybe is beginning to sprout legs and
can climb up the wall of the well a
little bit or if it rains the next day
or if the egg slips a little bit well
that egg becomes lunch and the male wins
either way assuming he hasn't
uh walked away from his well and someone
else hasn't come in and fathered the
deadpool in the weld and he wins either
way he either gets a new kid or he gets
to feed his old kid and win-win
heather figured this out under
really challenging field conditions like
really
tough ones right there's no field
station this was all uh very you know
like it was it was gilligan's island at
some level
and and
when you were sorting all of this out
measuring well ph water height you know
doing all the work necessary to sort
this out you were running the risk that
you were going to get barked into
cardiac arrest by a
pilot
right and you know that that could
happen and i did i mean i i still bear
faintly the scar having been attacked by
a lemur fulvis
sure but you know
you're not impressed you weren't there
for that believe me i was i contemplated
my mortality lying with a giant wound on
my arm wondering
what i had done to draw the ire of this
lemur who attacked me yes the lemur who
was actually
uh
justifiably all right irate at having
been captured turned into a pet and then
released on this island when nobody
could handle him well and i think she
was actually in love with one of the two
conservation agents and didn't like a
female showing up
um
yes yeah
anyway that's all that got so poppery
pretty quickly we'll just leave that
yeah
i do relate actually i tell the lemur
story and most of this in antipode which
is my first book soap opera it was
dentificy because as i recall when you
got attacked by the lemur you were
brushing your teeth am i wrong i was
brushing my teeth in fact the amazing
felix
when i went into town to seek to get
medical help um did
say ah well of course lemurs love
toothpaste
well what's not to love what
where did you come without that okay
lemurs love toothpaste but they do not
squeeze it from the bottom of the tube
no they like you squeeze it from the
middle
which turns out to be i just saw a
defense i suck i just saw a
defensiveness completely defensible the
cat even the cat's born and they
traumatized us over this in the 70s um
all right this has gotten weird but it's
kind of weird i guess i'm sort of
operating on the theory that we've been
thrown off of all social media we're
just talking to each other is that not
well i apologize we didn't lose all of
them with all that talk about frogs and
excellent okay
um
let's see
um
there's a lot of good questions here
we've already been at it for a while
you're totally boring the cat
it's easy to bore this cat
honey lemon tea suggestion add some
ginger for sure also peppercorns and
cloves
yeah i have i have
i haven't actually done that to the
honey lemon tea because it feels so pure
and amazing as it is uh but ginger gotta
love ginger yeah and um yeah pepper do
you crush the peppercorns i wonder just
put them in hall and then we actually
still we know we just ran out
of both we are at the very end speaking
of madagascar of the cloves and the
vanilla that i brought back from
madagascar which is now gosh that's over
that's over two decades yes so i i for
the first time just this week i bought
vanilla beans having having been living
on the vanilla beans that i bought from
sulu my friend the vanilla farmer
uh in the mishwa peninsula in like 1999.
anyway um yeah it's a good idea
ginger peppercorns cloves
i've wondered why trump didn't fire
fouchy in the insight as to why he
didn't
i don't think he's fireable somehow i
agree and actually i heard somebody else
i i was thinking of
um
calling him the j edgar hoover of public
health and i heard somebody else did
that exact phrase this week yeah um
i do think that there's some and you
know in jade hoover's case we know why
more or less
which is that because of his position at
the fbi he had enough goods on enough
people that nobody wanted
you know to
to go after him yeah right yeah that
can't be quite right with fouchy it's
not the same position on the other hand
we do know a lot about
his
the way he has ruled
um
public health and related fields
through
so much of science
yeah i mean it obviously doesn't extend
beyond a certain level but but there's a
there's an ability to
cause your
fortunes to reverse right if you're on
factory's good side the money can flow
and you can
start rising in your field if you're
run afoul of him it can be the end of
your career and so i think the answer is
heather and i know nothing about the
detail of how that worked but yeah
imagine for a second a system in which
somebody has amassed so much power and
remember he did turn down i believe
the
attempt to promote him
to nih yes that is um yeah uh bush ii i
believe tried to
try to promote him to nih and he uh
politely declined and i think basically
his his
fiefdom he had he had and retains more
power
uh as head of the niaid than he would
have as nih and you know collins who i
guess is stepping or has already stepped
down is normally his boss but not really
right so i think the thing is why would
somebody turn down that promotion and
the answer is um because
i have built all of these things into
this position that allow me card blanche
and why would i start over or
yeah just as many or just have to
oversee more like
why he's not a bureaucrat
he's a lot of things but i don't think
he's actually a bureaucrat
i don't know what he is um
[Music]
maybe that's not the right formulation
i don't know i'm thinking about i i
think i think it you know putting him in
a
a known category is bound to be a
mistake
yeah
he's special
um
related-ish
steve kirsch says rfk junior for
president
possible jfk's integrity lives on in him
jfks and rfk's integrity does live on in
him and rfk jr
i don't think it's possible yeah i don't
i don't see i don't think it's i think
he's been he's been so
slandered he's been
his his public image is so
not a match for the man
um but that is a
that i i don't think it's possible
let's put it this way i i don't think
it's possible
in the world we live in yeah i think the
world that we could live in if we ever
get the story of what happened in covid
yeah is a different world and i realize
this is going to sound crazy to some
people because they have
a lot of
stored up beliefs about what rfk jr is
and isn't i would point out however
though
um
there are a lot of people out there with
a false story running
around about them that if you run afoul
of power
it does certain things and yeah um
anyway so uh a certain amount of
agnosticism would be wise if you don't
have
a detailed understanding of what's going
on there indeed
here we have a haiku
tsunami coming in
no
so it's all in one line so i gotta count
it out to figure out what the lines are
tsunami coming
in interconnected worlds
wavefront was broadcast
it's good yeah that is good
sorry i butchered it the first time
i used to assign
uh
students to write poetry about concepts
they thought they understood because you
could figure out whether you did
understand it and sometimes you could
get deeper understanding if you forced
yourself and the the high bar was a
haiku that successfully
uh worked for some difficult concept
yeah so love the idea yeah
um let's see we've been at it for an
hour haven't we zach uh you've been at
it for an hour and five minutes five
minutes
um
a lot more covered questions
let's just pick two more quickly okay
uh what are your thoughts on quebec
imposing a health tax on the
unvaccinated and the potential
ramifications
um
as i
said before i remember i'm old enough to
remember
a day when this authoritarian nonsense
couldn't possibly have happened in the
west two years ago
you know this is just like every day
you're reading about um authoritarian
overreach
um the othering of people i mean how
insane would this have to be the damn
vaccine doesn't prevent this disease in
fact there is very strong increasingly
strong evidence that you're actually
more likely to contract it so someone
someone actually did ask that like what
i i've heard that but i haven't seen the
papers i haven't like i don't know what
the evidence for that is well i don't
think it's rock solid but i'm it is
increasingly strong
let's put it this way both what studies
have you read that indicate facts are
more likely to contract omicron if so
are we seeing early stages of ade so two
port questions let's just make this ade
is not the only mechanism that can do
this is the problem sure but first first
just let's address the like
what
what's what's the evidence
well it's like everything else it is
unfortunately compromised by the garbage
categories that don't allow us to see
who's in what state right so you have
okay
are you vaccinated what does that mean
does that mean are you okay but some
some parsing of the evidence makes it
look to some people like the vaxxed are
more likely to get armor yes including
including the great barrington
declaration doctors who published a
editorial in the uh
wall street journal i believe last week
in which they behind this club they make
this claim and i believe it's hot linked
and they point okay to it so anyway i
would invite you to take a look at that
um
but let's put it this way the fact that
this is even ambiguous tells you that
you have no justification for mandating
that anybody get these vaccines right if
it is debatable whether you are more or
less
likely to contract the disease and
there's no reduction in your
your viral load and therefore the
likelihood of you transmitting it
who in hell gets to tell you you need a
vaccine that could plausibly make you
more vulnerable and doesn't prevent
anybody else from getting it to you i
guess
what
what it just it's the height of insanity
right this is telling that
i shouldn't do this here
but
omicron is telling you that what we were
beginning to understand earlier in the
pandemic that the response to covid
makes no sense that in some sense our
worst fears were right
right given omicron much should have
changed about the recommendations from
public health authorities and the fact
that it didn't tells you this isn't
about public health
can i put you in the hot seat for a
minute
i guess um
it's the end of the it's we're done um
the end of the podcast as we know it i
feel like it's i feel fine you feeling
nervous yeah um i i'm wondering
um
you in particular and i also but
you in particular
advocated very strongly and for quite a
long time
for very short very intense and complete
lockdowns
[Music]
like
two weeks of like no one interacts with
anyone that they're not living with
two weeks though
this is before early treatment existed
or was known to exist well i mean i
guess that's that's i mean i think early
treatment was actually known to exist
but it's before you knew before yeah
yeah yeah um
so maybe maybe you just answered the
question then um
i know your question is is there a
situation
um that you can imagine in the future
when you for some as of yet unspecified
pathogen where you would i mean and
it's of course also putting aside like
is it even possible yep an actual like
complete yep lock down for you know
really
[ __ ] finite though um can you imagine
advocating for that in the future
well let's put it this way
the bar would be a lot higher because we
have now seen so much in the way of
shenanigans over claims about what is
true of these pathogens that i would be
very hesitant because
who's to say whether we will be fed a
bunch of garbage in order to get us to
agree to some stuff
that isn't actually about public health
again however
i do believe
a
here's the hard part of the question
you've got two worlds
one world you
get ahead of covid and you drive it to
extinction okay
the other world
you
dick around
and it becomes endemic and you're stuck
with it yep
the price of covid to humanity is not
comparable in these two scenarios we
can't say it's a thousand times greater
in scenario two because it's
indefinitely greater based on the fact
that you're going to keep paying the
price even if the price is small every
year how many years is humanity stuck
with sars kov2's descendants right this
is insane and you know another thing
how much life was lost
not how many lives were lost that's not
a good question how much life did each
of us lose and i believe each of us have
had our our
life expectancy dropped by by the
botching of covet by the release of it
and the botching of it but nonetheless
the point is
the argument for a severe intense very
short-lived lockdown was that we had no
mechanism of controlling this disease
inside of a house right it gets into
your house it ricochets around but it's
a short duration for each of the people
and so the point is for any given house
you could burn it out if it's in your
house it would ricochet around and then
be burned out nobody would be capable of
transmitting it to anybody so when you
went back to interacting
it would be effectively gone and then
the second part of the argument was that
will not be perfectly effective there
will be houses in which something weird
happens
and the point is then you need to have
high quality testing and you need to
find the places where the intense
lockdown didn't work right and then you
need to chase down those things so it's
a one-two punch
that would be thoroughly justified by
the advantage of not living in a world
with coveted on the loose forever right
this is long since passed us by as a
possibility so i would say
there are circumstances in which you
could justify a very short intensive
lockdown but here's the key for all of
those of you who are looking at me like
what did you lose your mind
i do not believe that the governmental
structure
that would be capable of doing this
honorably
exists i don't believe it exists on
earth i don't believe it's been
formulated which means i believe there
is one tool and one tool only that they
are entitled to use should such a
lockdown be justified on the basis of a
we've got a clock ticking and we've got
to drive this thing to extinction
otherwise we're going to get stuck with
it forever the one tool that they are
allowed to use
is persuasion
they have to convince us and persuasion
does not mean we're going to throw all
of the dissidents off of social media
and then pretend we have a consensus
about the right thing to do it means
we are all going to get to use all tools
available we are going to listen to
whoever we want we're going to let the
argument be fully aired and if you
haven't convinced us that there's a good
reason that we should want to do this
because we don't want our grandchildren
dealing with this
pathogen then you lose you can't do it
right
and if that was unclear if it was if
that was
unclear before it is absolutely clear
now
based on the way the corruption of this
system has abused
their leverage over us
um to the nth degree
so
the answer is yes in a theoretical way
but persuasion is their only legitimate
tool in anybody who wants to step into
mandate land um we're going to see them
coming next time
yeah
all right
well this was this was long today but
fun yeah yeah it was good and so we will
be again we will be uh friday
afternoon our time next week rather than
saturday midday
and
you know all the things yeah you can
pick up our book and join us on our
patreons
take a look at my sub stack um pretty
much all the stuff on my sub stack is
for free so you can you can join without
paying anything and just get a email
once a week or so
with the new posts uh you
you can
drive up drive down drive over to
washington dc you could fly in you could
fly down you could
scroll over to defeatthemandatesdc.com
you could do that that would be a good
thing to do that's a first step first
step to the side am i going to drive i'm
going to fly am i going to flap my wings
right i mean i believe you're morally
hummingbirds inspired to defeat the
mandates but you could go to the website
just for some ideas on how that might be
done
um and
i don't know maybe that's it maybe
that's it
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
you